hey what's up guys my name is the
churner welcome back to my c++ series
today we'll be talking all about how you
can store any kind of data in a single
variable in c++ a lot of you are
probably thinking well yeah you can do
that with a void pointer and yes that's
true and I'll have a video about void
pointers coming soon in the future
however this is a much of a better way
it's a safer way and it's a supercilious
17 brand new way of doing things I've
had this kind of miniseries lately on
how we can store different types of data
and single variables in C++ there's
something called S City optional S City
variants and now we're going to be
talking about S City any and I've
already made videos about the other two
so if you haven't seen the video about
optional data or the video about how we
can store multiple variables multiple
data types in a single variable then
check out those videos they'll be linked
up there so now we're kind of here at
the end we're up to the point where
using STD any we can store anything and
I think that the bigger question here is
not how do I use STD any I think that's
pretty straightforward as we'll see in a
minute it's why does this exist when do
we want to use it and why would we use s
UV Eddie instead of something like a
city variant
all brilliant things that wouldn't be
talking about today but first let's talk
about our sponsor for today's video
Skillshare I'm sure you guys have
probably heard of Skillshare before it's
an online learning community with
thousands of classes covering dozens of
creative and entrepreneurial skills with
unlimited access to all of these classes
so that you can join the ones that are
right for you since I'm more of an
engineer that an artist I really like
all of the creative classes that
Skillshare has to offer
for example this class is a fantastic
reference for whenever I need to make a
new logo Skillshare are also one of my
go-to references for anytime I need to
deal with web stuff because let's be
honest I want to spend as little time as
possible hunt at and with these small
concise videos I can get through this
stuff quickly Scotia are offering two
months of free membership to anyone who
signs up using the link in the
description below two months free
membership for two months think about
how much you could learn in two months
so go ahead and check that out and I
want to give a huge thank you to skill
chef
during this video as you guys know I'm
quite new to doing this YouTube thing
full time and it's amazing companies
like that who make this possible anyway
see what I did there is that any way
because we're talking about SVP any
let's just jump into the code so the
first thing that we're gonna do is
include the header file which is just
any just like that also make sure that
you are of course compiling this code
with C++ 17 because this is a C++ 17
only feature it's new in C++ 17 I should
say because obviously if using a version
newer than that presumably it would
still be there unless the committee
decided that it was a terrible idea
which still convinced it might be and in
that case it's gone but let's just
pretend that it's gonna be here forever
because it might so to use this you
simply write s city any it's much like
variant except there are no template
arguments because of course it's it can
store any type then we just will type in
a name for our variable call it data you
can use something called SUV make any if
you want to construct something from
here but what we'll do is we'll just
kind of keep it empty here and then just
set data equal to like two for example
and then we can set data equal to a
constant star pointer or we can say died
or equal to a string in which case we'll
just write something like this or we
could set it equal to you guys kind of
get the point you just set it equal to
like absolutely anything because that's
what it is any thing if you want to
retrieve your data you're gonna have to
do a little bit more work you'll have to
actually know which type it is and then
kind of cast it into that type and you
can do that by using s city any cost
then you just put in the type that you
want to cast to like STD string and then
of course the actual any variable goes
into the parameter here now this will
throw an exception about any cast
exception if the data is not of the type
that you're trying to cast into so just
keep that in mind there's a course for
return a string so we can assign it like
so now first glance this may seem like
it's pretty much the same as STD variant
and that's because well it's similar
right we can store any type here whereas
STD variant requires us to list all of
our types but see whilst a lot of people
might think that s to be very
is worse because you have to list all
your types words here you don't have to
worry about types at all that's kind of
why SUT variant is actually better than
SCT anything pretty much anything you
need to deal with I'm really getting
annoyed with saying the word any all the
time the fact that SUV variant requires
you to list out all of those types is
good that's what makes it type safe for
example we might forget to explicitly
write the fact that this is a string and
we might try and write some code like
this this looks perfectly reasonable we
set data to two we set data to Cherno
which is a string and then we try and
get that string out however that's not
going to work because well this chatter
is not a string is it it's just a
constant our pointer whereas if we were
using variant in this exact scenario
then our code would look something like
this we might have int we might have STD
string now of course this will work
correctly and we'd have to change this
to be get maybe get if because this will
get implicitly cast into a string cause
it has to be either a string or an int
so are there any differences between
variant and any apart from the fact that
variant of course requires you to list
out the types well yes it's to do with
how they're stored variant is simply a
type safe Union what that means is that
it stores all of its data in basically a
union and again if you guys are not
familiar with that there is a video in
the top right corner just about unions
what does any do well let's take a look
if we just go into this header file then
we can see all of the code for any a lot
of people ask me how does this work how
does that work and my answer is just
take a look
STL is the sanno template library it's
implemented in all in header files and
you've got all of those files all that
source code on your computer so just
open them up and try and read it I know
it can be hard sometimes because of the
way that is written but just take it
slowly and you'll be surprised at how
much you'll actually understand so
looking at this header file we can start
to piece together how this actually
works
we know that storage seems to be the
variable that stores well something and
you can see that what it is is actually
a union let's take a look at what
storage T is it's a struct which seems
to have a small storage of big storage
an aligned Union and if we actually take
a look at what big storage T for example
is it's a void pointer surrounded by a
bunch of padding and small storage is
actually just an aligned Union T which
digging in even deeper we realize is an
aligned union of all of the types so
what s it e an e actually does and I
think this is quite clever is for small
types it just stores them as a union
which means that for small types it
works in exactly the same way as a
variant however if you have a large type
that's where it actually takes you into
that void pointer big storage and in
that case it will actually dynamically
allocate memory now dynamically
allocating memory is not good for
performance so to sum up how this works
if you're using a variant or SUV Eddy
with small types like integers floats
you know maybe like a vector for class
or something like that like in a math
library you'll be flying I mean they're
gonna work in exactly the same way and
you can see by looking here at the
source code that that small storage
which is all the way up here happens to
be if we take a look at this align Union
and specifically there's any small space
size variable you can see that it is
around 32 bytes now this may be
implementation specific obviously I'm
using visual studio with MSB C it's 32
bytes so if you have more storage than
that at that point SC DNA will
dynamically allocate however SCV variant
will not so in other words apart from
being more typesafe and a little bit
more restrictive which is a good thing
every variant is also going to perform
faster if you happen to deal with larger
data or you want to avoid dynamic memory
allocation another tip that I can give
you for faster performance is to make
sure that you don't copy data so you can
see that over here with string I am of
course copying it if we go back to our
sed any way of doing things
you need to make sure that you return
this by reference and if you do that
you'll see it doesn't work natively like
this so this is something that actually
would have worked with SVG yet with any
cost it doesn't make sure that you
actually stick the reference into the
template argument here if you punt
return by reference and that will of
course make sure that everything is
nicely optimized and you can see that in
this actual case obviously make sure
that we actually use sed string in our
control point in this case we won't
actually get any memory
allocations apart from the one that will
probably come up from string and it's
actually very easy to test this you can
just replace operator new with one of
your own by writing some simple code
like this this is not a complete good
implementation of the new operator so
don't use this in any production code
obviously but if we stick a breakpoint
in here then we'll now be aware of all
memory allocations and if I hit f5 to
run this program you'll see that we do
get a memory allocation but if we take a
look at where it comes from it actually
comes from a city string so you can see
over here if I make the call stack a
little bit bigger
we have SCV basic string which then goes
into the allocator and if I go back to
main and I just step through that code a
little bit so we'll go back up here
we'll just step out of that and then
just go to the next line if we take a
look at this call stack a little bit
more closely it might actually seem like
any is the one doing the allocation
because you can see it comes from the
assignment operator to any but all any
is actually doing is doing a construct
in place forwarding all those arguments
and it's the basic string you can see
that is allocating once again so f5 to
continue running this and again we have
a basic string and that is all of the
allocations from this program so in that
case s-u-v any actually did not allocate
anything if however we were to have some
kind of class that would have more than
32 bytes so for example I'll have a
struct here of two strings s0 and s1 if
I do try and actually set this up over
here I'll just use custom class and we
will remove this anycast and if I had f5
if I skip past this basic string
allocation that of course is coming from
the member variables of that custom
class then you'll see that what we have
here is that assignment operator and
during the emplacement you can see that
this is a big storage operation which of
course does actually call new over here
so just be aware that sed NE will
allocate if it needs to and in this case
if the data that you're trying to store
is above 32 bytes you can see that it
calls new and causes a dynamic memory
allocation so back to the question of
when to use sed any when should it be
used this is a tricky one a lot of
people will just flat-out tell you that
it's just a bit useless and to be honest
I'm kind of inclined to agree when well
look what is a good use case for SED
Annie if you want to store multiple data
types in a single variable use SV
variant it's basically a type safe
version of STD any meaning that you
can't set it to whatever type you please
accidentally and also it's not going to
dynamically allocate memory so it will
perform better if you have the need the
requirement to be able to store any data
type in a single variable maybe rethink
the design of your program I mean I
honestly really like kind of think of a
valid use case for this I think that
it's I think that it's something that
you probably should never use I mean if
you have like a buffer of data and you
have like absolutely no idea what that
outer is you just want to you just want
to point it to it then that's fine you
can use a void pointer for that but this
is like this is something completely
different if you guys have any good use
cases if you guys have used this
throughout your code and you think that
it's useful please drop a comment below
I'd love to read some of those comments
and see because as it stands right now I
don't think this is anywhere near as
useful as optional or variant and it's
kind of funny I guess to end to end the
series on something like this but that's
just the way it is I just think that s
it eeny is something that you should
definitely be aware of but maybe not
something that you should use all that
often anyway I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did you can hit that
like button also don't forget to check
out the link in description for two
months of free Skillshare membership you
can also drop a comment below if you
want me to cover a specific topic in C++
and I will add it to my ever-growing
list I will see you guys next time
goodbye strong
[Music]